THIS UP BECAUSE IT'S LIKELY
HELPING HIM INTERNALLY.
>> Reporter: NORTH KOREA'S
VIOLENT ERRATIC YOUNG LEADER'S
LATEST PROVOCATION, TRIGGERING
GUNFIRE.
TONIGHT THE HEAVILY FORTIFIED
BORDER IS ON A RAZOR'S EDGE OF A
SOUTH KOREAN FORCES FIRED AT AN
UNMANNED DRONE.
IT QUICKLY RETURNED, QUOTE,
TOWARDS THE NORTH.
WHAT WAS LIKELY THE MISSION?
>> IT WAS PROBABLY TACTICAL
RECOG
RECOGNIZANCE.
IT'S LIKELY THEY WERE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT TROOP DISPOSITION.
THE SECOND THING OBVIOUSLY
PROBABLY PROVOCATION.
>> Reporter: KIM JONG-UN IS ALSO
ENGAGING IN AN INTENSE
PROPAGANDA BATTLE.
IN SEOUL AND SOME BORDER CITY,
SOUTH KOREAN TROOPS PICKED UP
LEAFLETS DROPPED BY NORTH KOREAN
BALLOONS, AN INCITEMENT TO
ATTACK SOUTH KOREAN'S PRESIDENT.
SOUTH KOREA HAD LAUNCHED ITS
OPEN PROPAGANDA IN RECENT DAYS.
LOUD SPEAKER BROADCASTS BLARING
ACROSS THE BORDER FOLLOWING
NORTH KOREA'S FOURTH NUCLEAR
TEST.
IN ANY POTENTIAL ESCALATION,
AMERICANS AND THEIR ALLIES ARE
THIS THE CROSS FIRE.
>> WHAT I REALLY WORRY ABOUT IS
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE TENSE OF
THOUSANDS OF TROOPS U.S. AND
SOUTH KOREAN LIKE A TRIP WIRE,
BOTH SIDES ARE STANDING THERE
ARMED AND FACING ON OF FOR ALL
THIS TIME HAS RESULTED IN THE
DEATH OF U.S. SOLDIERS ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS.
>> Reporter: ANALYSTS SAY LOOK
FOR KIM TO KEEP THE DANGEROUS
GAME GOING.
>> KIM JONG-UN IS WILLING TO
ENGAGE AND CONTINUE PROP
PROVOCATIONS IN PART BECAUSE IT
BENEFITS HIM DOMESTICALLY.
HE TELLS HIS PEOPLE NORTH KOREA
IS NOW DETONATED ALLEGEDLY A HOE
DROE AGAIN BOMB AND THIS MEANS
NORTH KOREA IS NOW A MEMBER OF
THIS VERY ELITE CLUB.
>> Reporter: U.S. OFFICIALS SAY
IT LIKELY WASN'T A HYDROGEN
BOMB, BUT TONIGHT KIM IS AGAIN
THREATENING NUCLEAR WAR WITH THE
U.S.
COULD HE CARRY OUT THAT THREAT?
>> HE IS CRAZY ENOUGH TO CREATE
AN INCIDENT THAT COULD GO
NUCLEAR.
BUT I DON'T THINK HE WOULD
LAUNCH A NUCLEAR WEAPON EXCEPT
IN THE MOST DESPERATE STRAIGHTS.
BUT HE COULD MISCALCULATE.
HE'S FULLY CAPABLE OF
MISCALCULATING.
>> Reporter: AND HERE IS ANOTHER
WEAPON THAT KIM COULD
MISCALCULATE WITH.
NORTH KOREA BOASTED IN RECENT
DAYS THEY HAVE CONDUCTED A
MISSILE LAUNCH FROM A SUBMARINE.
IS THIS A FREEZE GRAB OF VIDEO P
BUT ANALYSTS SAY THE TEST MAY
HAVE BEEN A FAILURE, THE VIDEO
APPEARS TO BE EDITED.
ON THE LEFT THEY SEE BLACK SMOKE
AND SEVERAL CAN MO